hey guys welcome to honest trailers
commentary the show where we talk about
the show where we talk about the other
shows and movies in television
I am Spencer de Gilbert the head writer
on trailers to my flow it's weird with
the monitor I guess this is my left yes
Dan Morrill and to my right is Joe star
hi guys you may notice someone's missing
and he's signor if you're curious about
where he is you can watch a different
video on screen jockeys what happened
and what's next or just Google yeah yeah
needless to say he will have nothing to
do with honest trailers going forward
he gets no royalties he has nothing to
do with it from here on out but we do so
we're gonna keep talking about here
we're gonna keep talking about these
things yeah and then yeah I guess full
disclosure is we had written and and
kind of we're ready to release this one
before all the things happened this is
actually like I haven't really thought
about this or looked at this one in like
lately yeah this one this one was on the
back burner for three weeks while we
were figuring out other things that do
respect to fans of the film spider-man
homecoming we're a few rungs up the
ladder
for us as far as things we needed to
figure out so yeah this is the product
of we came back and I think polished it
off a little bit yeah and kind of blew
the dust off of it and took another get
above it in the light of day but yeah
this is yeah this was gonna come out a
few weeks ago it would have come out a
few weeks ago it didn't
looking back on spider-man homecoming I
think it was super enjoyable I liked a
lot it's fun is a fun movie and I don't
know not really worth picking apart but
here we are that is what the Lord has
called us to do yeah yeah it's it's a
fun movie I am increasingly getting to
the point where Marvel movies I walk out
of the theater and I go yay next yet to
me they're like an episode of a
long-running TV show that I like yeah so
it's like another good installment of
Marvel the series
I feel like this was right in line with
that yeah forget pretty much yeah it's
better than guardians to for me
guardians to I walked out it was like
that was fine I don't remember anything
about it and this one stuck with me a
little better Michael Keaton was great
and yeah Michael Keaton its I'm glad
they had a I don't know the the vulture
vulture in the suit was the exact same
masked suited villain that Marvel has
always had however vulture out of the
suit as we point out this trailer that
was where the the greatness of that
villain was yeah it's kind of like a
Defoe's Green Goblin where you're like
wow Willem Dafoe's way scarier than that
mask yes yeah what is this weird toy
chasing Tobey Maguire at all totally so
I guess we have if you guys stick around
till after we watch a trailer and talk
about it there's some deleted scenes
deleted scenes yeah some alternate wills
and stuff alternate names we'll stop and
chat up some parts of the trailer as we
go I'm sure yes yeah this is we're back
we're back baby so roll it spider-man
homecoming video starts now careful if
you were my spoiler sense is tingling
it's I mean by now there's yeah but you
got to do
[Music]
since 2002 we've had six movies two
reboots and three spider-man now just
when audiences might be getting a little
sick of the franchise Marvel swoops in
to deliver a crowd-pleasing comedy
that's gonna keep spider-man in theaters
and to the [ __ ] Sun burns out of the
sky
spider-man homecoming this was a
rejuvenation for the I was done with
spider yes I have to raise experiment
two I was like okay I'm done
oh and they were talking about the
sinister six movie and I'm sorry I love
Tom Hardy but even the venom movie I'm
not thrilled by the prospect of but the
but when he showed up in Civil War like
alright okay I'll get shots good severed
yeah yeah it's fun I like that you
pointed out that it's a comedy cuz I
think this is what gives this movie a
little bit of an edge over a lot of
other Marvel movies is that it felt like
something other than a Marvel movie and
it felt like a good like it's a high
school movie yeah a high school comedy
movie and it gives it a different vibe
high school movie starring people that
looked like they could conceivably be in
high school and yeah thirty year old
James
I don't think completely undeserved shot
at the fact that Tobey Maguire and
Andrew Garfield like they don't get
carded anyway so let's keep going they
had held back a couple years Tobey
Maguire couldn't keep it up Andrew
Garfield couldn't get it started but Tom
Holland hits the ground swinging in a
great reboot that just assumes you're
all caught up on the MCU pretty sure
this guy's a war criminal now but
whatever complete with a glossed over
origin story an actor who doesn't have
premature old face the villain doesn't
already have some forced personal
connection to Peter Pan Liz's dad that's
the spider-man hallmark is all of the
villains are in some way shape or form
related too closely Peter Parker or
someone they love nobody else gets
superpowers it's nothing else like
everybody's Eve you know over from
capital city no it's always Peter
Parker's second cousin twice removed
happen to run into him on the street
someone except for was the Sandman no
remember the same man killed Uncle Ben
yeah no he didn't yeah
three the same man was the robber that
killed a little bin but didnt someone
kill his daughter too he was a little
lovable yeah he was trying to take care
of his daughter that's why he did it all
sure I take care was art then he like
wandered into like a sand nuke testing
the radioactive sand new testing sighs
we all deal with grief in different ways
yeah he accidentally killed Uncle Ben
Uncle Ben yeah as you do again as you do
I think he was the partner of the guy
that you saw it was one of those real
answers like it wasn't that guy it was
the other yeah he felt really bad about
it cause so we wired to cry yeah again
and then he was like have you ever
danced with the devil ran away to be in
the sand Peter Parker should just
prematurely imprison everyone he's ever
known I agree okay solving a lot of
problems also that's my second favorite
joke in this trailer the the heart cut
to Michael Keaton going I'm Liz is also
not a knock until we wires appearance
just on the knock that he had a
prematurely old face for someone who's
supposed to be playing an 18 year old
yeah I mean as did everyone yeah as did
everyone in Jim Franco like they're all
girl grown they're all not very much not
18 years old yeah for that weird kid
that's just shaving twice a day yeah
they were all the oldest looking kid in
the class yeah but a lot of whole-milk
[Laughter]
relic JD you go a new take on spider-man
he's a millennial now and can't stay off
his bone
constantly vlogs watches himself on
YouTube and as he would anything he's
got all the usual spider skills plus a
powerful new one never facing
consequences for his actions whether
he's getting away with ditching
detention we're gone get back here
quitting on his team you can't just quit
on a stroll up and be welcome back
welcome back Peter mostly imprisoning
people
Shinsuke ours is bad my cards on that
wrecking a car wrecking the store
wrecking a fairy or wrecking his
girlfriend's entire life you can be sure
this website will get off with no more
than a stern talking-to you're a good
kid and you're a smart kid so just try
to keep your head straight okay okay
don't get out here does he get a pass
because he's a teenager figuring it out
it is ironic that a superhero whose core
found founding principles
responsibilities very little responsible
yeah he seems to acknowledge that he had
some responsibilities but doesn't
necessarily share the burden of that
well this is sort of the one spot where
the movie falls off because like overall
with like the plot between him and Tony
I feel like they tried to make that arc
about him becoming more responsible but
like at no point other than doing his
beat up Michael Keaton thing does he
like become responsible well also he
stashes a plane and a huge beach even in
the midst of learning responsibilities
that there are grossly irresponsible
acts and it does track that like Tony
would be the person to influence him in
that way because Tony Stark like
international arms dealer no
responsibility yeah like threaten the
world multiple times by his own hand and
is still just allowed to run the
government
i spiderman is basically a james spader
voice away from being Ultron
collateral damage no real a concept of
what he's doing
very lucky his only likely she's happy
Hogan he's like already got his hands
full and doesn't even want any or is it
yeah yeah yeah yeah I think what this
movie really needed was like he doesn't
get to go back to the debate team just
like small things like that like at the
end of this movie his life should be
kind of blown up and he should have to
deal with it because he's spider-man but
yeah yeah then again we all we all work
also very tired of the kind of angsty
guilt-ridden spider-man you know what do
we want so instead they have him have to
lift something heavy as his like
emotional I'll fight for that scene I
love that scene it was a great way to
build his character without having to be
very what was it saying about his
character like now he can lift things it
was it was no it was say that he had
looked externally for validation
metaphorical lifts it was a metaphorical
lift it's saying that you know you can't
rely on other people or a crutch to be a
heroes like you have to be the human
would find it within yourself I like
that see I'll fight for that it's from
the books I know it's from the books but
that means it's great what you've seen
him as Batman and Birdman now prepare
for Michael Keaton's third winged
creature role as the vulture he's a
blue-collar guy who gets shafted by
Stark Industries and instead of filing a
lawsuit against a billionaire clearly in
the wrong he'll build a giant bird mech
jetpack huh you will be punished when
Fulcher fights spider-man in bland cgi
slugfests but genuinely scared when he's
just being Michael Keaton are you scared
I'm that you're glad
pal spider-man showed up in the elevator
[Music]
Parker there's a new absentee dad in
town Tony Stark Iron Man is back as the
drunk rich stepfather you'd expect him
to be who build you a killer robot suit
in touch when he's in India and drinking
and then it cuts back to spider-man
talking to the drone and the drone is
just like yeah has a couple days notice
that yeah it's just like his arm is
randomly out then you realize oh cuz
Tony's holding a beverage I want to know
what this meeting was uh was about and
if it went well how does this connect to
infinity Wars yeah is that the new
Mandarin yeah who is he meeting with why
is there alcohol that mango lassi cuz
there shouldn't be Tony you have right
problem yeah I was just wondering who
build you a killer robot suit activating
instant kill send you into battle at 15
then literally phone in his parenting
until you screw up enough to get his
attention okay it's not working out I'm
gonna need the suit back really Tony you
just bought your best friend over
keeping tabs on superheroes and you just
let your pet superhero run amok is
anyone paying attention to the timeline
anymore
this is approaching x-men levels of
sloppy she sends Bishop back in time no
just his consciousness into his younger
self I mean there's that there's the
there's the continuity issue which is
that actually I didn't think about that
till we were doing this was like yes
Civil War was all about Tony like
literally ripping the Avengers apart for
this idea of superhero Registration
oversight over of which spider-man
apparently has none with except for Tony
which that's awesome
noting that so that yeah I was like that
was strange it seemed like they just
kind of discarded that part but we
didn't mention the the continuity of
years which this movie also appears to
have gotten wrong because someone had
constructed the timeline that this movie
is in I always just assumed that the it
was roughly like the years that the
movies came out like they were all just
supposed to be current day but then if
you look it I think it's guardians like
they actually named
date see then you can kind of reverse
engineered the dates from that and this
takes place like eight years after the
Avengers or I mean a civil war or
something like that yeah it was like The
Avengers had set a certain date and this
movie said it was eight years after that
date which would have put it like three
years from now however a civil war had
occurred at a certain date so like none
of apparently just I I think this was
Sony's touch hmm I think Marvel was like
we will let you determine the number of
years that have occurred and they're
like eight and they messed up and so
yeah again this was I don't know this is
a weird movie that it's just very weird
just continuity between like it's part
of the MCU but it's I will say it
doesn't bother me cuz like I don't as a
comics fan we've been having to deal
with like Marvel's weird sliding scale
timeline since the 60s where like Peter
was in high school and now he's like a
young entrepreneur but he you know like
this seems like an easy and unforced
error like exactly slide rule out I mean
Kevin Feige I'm sure has these dates
tattooed on the inside of his eyelid you
think they he has a bunch of memento
tattoos of the phases exactly right like
I don't care about the x-men timeline if
it gives us good stories and good movies
I just feel like because it was so
unimportant to the story that's being
told why not just get the date right
yeah yeah no that's totally fair seem
strange very sloppy but we didn't want
to go into the whole thing about the
time because it's up for debate is box
hey let's keep our chairs so enjoy
another super smash so success was far
from guaranteed with two competing
Studios fighting for control six
different screenwriters and a director
with just two low-budget Indies to his
name yes we should
it's like Sony finally cracked the code
on how to make the spider-verse happen
let Marvel do the work a starring Tom
Netherlands and stars only winners do
drugs as a serum a disembodied voice of
Jennifer Connelly you can call me Karen
if you would like Marisa told me she
went after Hulk vulture or the
unexpected virtue of casting Michael
Keaton
technically in the movie chilli ravioli
pixie Jane girls hey there's the playing
The Perks of Being a Wallflower great
title to to thank you not nearly as good
as hanging out in an elevator shaft
spider-man can't catch a break with that
should we apologize to Martin Starr now
for any is that a bad thing
I feel like there will be some honest
trailer fans that are gonna see him and
go I'm sure he does it yeah elementary
school when that movie came out I would
have gotten it too so there would have
been some kid that'd be like hey oh
that's funny nerds
yet to me it was just a shock and then
realize you know of course this is the
case like Martin Starr and Hannibal
Buress are think of them as young people
and it just shows how old I am now that
like they they're the lame adults now
that was scary
oh that's scary yeah that hurts was
Martin stars character his character and
Incredible Hulk that at Norton gives the
pizza - oh yeah that's right and then
Jennifer comedy holds up that pizza for
so long that's the one thing I remember
about that movie right yeah it's like a
30-second shot up to him just holding up
a slice of pizza and smiling and nodding
yeah to establish that he has pizza
because they've established that Peter
Parker's high school principal is the
I'm assuming grand ransom the howling
commando from which he because they have
the pictures and also it wasn't that
Peter in to they say that it's Peter at
the at the expose a little kid that
holds his hand up to - yeah get the they
shouldn't say things like this anymore
it's a trap they're trapped themselves
into a timeline that they can't yeah you
guys don't like this you don't don't do
it Marvel unforced error keep it vague
keep it vague yeah it could have said
some years later or yeah several years
later years later
many years later no had to be very
specific about exactly how many know
well I should do some deleted scenes
antics let's do it let's check it out
starring spider-man 3 happy meal crabby
Hogan he was Chrissa Aunt May and miles
more or less childish cameo not Deb
Patel that's his badge of the nurse King
of Queens whoa
I had no idea Ultimate Comics spider-man
1 was a nod to Donald Glover's license
plate and where's the joke because it's
fabric that it's not a good job yeah I
apologize oh yeah don't worry I'm sorry
I just got it I thought you were just
giving us some trivia until I actually
listened to that my head was like oh
wait
[Music]
yeah now Gwen Stacy fund on the
elevators better yeah like that I'm sure
that we even see the new leader shaft
it's a clock tower mmm
I guess we don't have the clip I guess
there was other stuff that maybe was in
the script but the we talked about Mary
Jane zendaya zendaya zendaya she's
eating bread and she's got a ponytail
yeah I think we had we all had kind of
different takes I didn't mind it you
were very annoyed I wasn't a note on her
character yeah I was not a fan right I
was not a fan personally I was in day
I'm sure is lovely a lovely person
however I was not a fan of the character
that I don't know it was just like it
felt a little Cornish in the sense of
just like is this a person from the
mythology we're like yeah it's Mary Jane
and they're like but is it like ya know
we know it is like but what if it's not
we're like no we know who it is and they
just tease it out to the whole movie and
then he's like I'm Mary Jane I'm like
yeah I know I was paying as much
attention as you like just take on its
own terms you just didn't like which I
just thought she was there to roll her
eyes he's a book and roller I liked her
a lot and I I hate the Mary Jane thing
just because that's not married like the
point of Mary Jane's character was she
was like this like super model girl and
completely out of Peter Parker's League
and she's like a whole different thing
you had a chance to just make a cool new
character like you don't need to slap a
name on her and I know it's not Mary
Jane yeah just don't just let her be a
cool new thing man
yeah I like her fair enough yeah fair
enough
well guys said it it also didn't make me
want to punch a wall I will say that it
didn't make you what did not make like I
was like yeah but it didn't make me rage
out of the theater like yeah I guess I
liked it I didn't have a problem with it
until they were like kill me MJ Robin
Robin VidCon it's like really yeah
my first name's Robin no it's not no
one's person it was Robin Robin right
robin Leach Robin Williams Robin
Williams okay you stand corrected
his name was Robin
but overall yeah good good quick yeah
enjoyable it was a it was like a high
school comedy with the superhero movie
bolted onto it which i think is the
marble model now is to take other genres
and just fill them with superheroes mhm
which I feel like that gives them
longevity they can keep doing that till
till the Sun burns out the effing sky
yes we said we do call Tony Revell
Laurie Tony ravioli yeah he's a friend
of the show friend of the chef so I'm
sure he's very happy that we've now
taken our nickname for him and put it in
its eternal net for all the sifts it's
Tony
you're welcome so yeah I guess we'll
also be doing these until the Sun burns
out of the sky which means that we'll be
here next week for another one that we
kind of started a while ago but we'll
get to and we've been wanting to do for
a while the delay on this one maybe I'll
do it more conspicuous we will talk
about that we'll talk about it next week
and we'll hopefully see you guys then
thanks for watching
[Music]
you